uh you mentioned Bitcoin the last time
we talked I think was towards the
beginning of 2022 uh and you uh
rightfully said hey I think bitcoin's
gonna crash uh you were smart enough not
to put an exact uh price Target or a uh
timeline on it but you're like sometime
this year I think it would be like a
correction uh talk a little bit now in
hindsight after having said that uh kind
of this year and how it's transpired how
much of it fit within what you thought
was going to happen versus you got the
intended outcome but maybe some of the
details were different good question so
you know in in the economy obviously the
way that I look at it anyway is that
housing and transportation can often be
leading indicators of the economy and so
what I was seeing when I was here with
you last earlier this year was I was
seeing some of the deterioration and
housing right because it's a leading
indicator and so then what you saw also
from my perspective was you saw a
deterioration in lumber pricing and so
you started to see some of these
Commodities that had gotten so big so
fast you know in terms of price and so I
said it's only a matter of time before
you know the drain and liquidity coupled
with these commodity disinflation
affects Bitcoin and so that's why I had
said that what are your thoughts about
Bitcoin now price has gone down 75 I
think you're still holding Bitcoin you
like Bitcoin is that all true yes and
I'm gonna wait to be buying a little bit
more I think that uh it's still a little
too expensive given liquidity Dynamic I
think we're going to have continued
liquidity problems in the market in my
opinion uh first quarter next year and
is that all being driven by the FED just
tightening Financial conditions keep
raising interest rates and selling off
assets you know again you're talking to
a housing guy so I have kind of a unique
perspective from an interest rate
standpoint we say in housing that
interest rates are the mother's milk of
Housing and so when you cut off the
mother's milk of housing in my opinion
that also goes Downstream into the
economy and so I think that these
interest rates the effects of these
interest rates has not really been felt
it's been felt in housing but I don't
think it's made itself to mainstream
business and as as you think about those
interest rates we've seen all year long
they've continued to increase we've seen
the sell-off of asset prices and they've
stated we want to destroy demand we want
to destroy demand they've done a
fantastic job on the investment appetite
side there is very little appetite for
investment at the moment
on the other side though you have
consumer spending you have a household
income you have savings like all these
other metrics that seem to still be like
fairly healthy how do you balance uh
destruction of investment assets and
investment prices with what still seems
to be a somewhat strong consumer I think
it's only a matter of time and I think
you know we're in the HVAC business
that's where I spend a lot of my time
direct to the homeowner and we are
seeing people being really reticent so
to speak to spend the big ticket items
that they were doing a year or two ago
so I think it's going to be a lag effect
and it's just a matter of time yeah and
that means that the FED at some point
will have to Pivot and I think they
already have I mean they went down to 50
basis points and
um you know I think they'll continue to
increase but it could be potentially
pretty tough four and a half percent now
what do you think they get to don't know
but I'll tell you six I don't know but
I'll tell you this these mortgage rates
are not very good I mean these are not
these are not very good things for the
housing market and so I think it's going
to be good for the housing market as a
buyer as a consumer I think it's going
to help a lot of people people but
the zoning in our country has made it in
my opinion to where in addition to
people not being able to build enough
because of the last recession people
don't want to build a lot of these big
subdivisions anymore and so I think
that's also going to keep housing prices
pretty high
when you evaluate the mortgage market
we've seen an explosion I know people
who are getting you know 2.2 2.5 percent
mortgages a year ago uh now all of a
sudden they're looking at five or six
percent is it literally just number goes
up demand goes down or is there more
complexity to it no it's literally as
simple as that I mean obviously you have
the wage issue as well but you have you
have basically if you dumb it down you
have interest rates and you have wages
and wages have stayed pretty strong
whether that's through inflation or
through you know the inertia in the
economy but you have this interest rate
situation and it definitely what it does
is it initially affects traffic and then
once you see it in traffic you see it in
orders and then once you see it in order
you start seeing it in cancellations of
homes and you've seen cancellations go
from you know in some of these cases 12
13 of orders to 25 percent of orders I
mean that's a huge increase yeah in in
cancellations people you know signing a
purchase agreement and then canceling it
later that's not good you know a quarter
of the homes being cancer